[Music]
Taylor Swift kicked off the 2018
American Music Awards with a fiery
performance of I did something bad and
boy did it feel so good
[Music]
[Music]
even got a surprise snake
[Music]
but before hitting the stage Taylor hit
the red carpet looking like a disco
Queen in the silver sparkling balm on
Minnie sitting since she took home a lot
of shiny Awards throughout the night
she's now the female with the most AMAs
so first of all I want to thank my tour
mates I want to thank Charli XCX and
Camilla Camilla she first took home the
AMA for tour of the year thank you so
much for winning this war with me then
it was Best pop/rock album she beat out
pal at Sheeran and Drake I always look
at albums as chapters in my life I have
to be really honest with you about
something and I'm even more excited
about the next chapter and finally day
took home the top honor artist of the
year and reminded us all with this award
and every single award given out tonight
we're voted on by the people and you
know what else is voted on by the people
is the midterm elections on November 6
dead on a boat I love you guys
[Music]